Bon, chéri, j'ai un truc à te dire.
Oui, quoi ?
Voilà, euh... avant de sortir avec toi, j'ai fréquenté un autre homme.
Ca c'est pas grave chérie, c'est normal, moi aussi j'ai eu des...
Oui mais...
C'était ton frère.
Ah ouais ?
Bah nan mais, c'est pas grave. C'est le passé.
C'est pas fini.
Parce que j'ai aussi eu une aventure avec ton cousin.
Le petit Lucas ?
Ouais, le petit Lucas et puis aussi avec euh... avec Steven.
Steven, mon meilleur ami ?
Mais bon euh... il voulait juste me réconforter après une histoire avec ton père, hein.
Et puis c'est pas fini parce que, aussi, y a eu Pascal, y a eu Martin ton collègue de la compta.
Y a eu Frédéric, y a eu Nelson, Cédric, super cool Cédric.
Ah ouais ?
Henri, tu vois qui c'est Henri ? Oh, c'était une horreur...
Gérard, Henri et Bernard en même temps, y a eu le prof de tennis.
Ta soeur Lorie, ton grand-oncle Michel.
Toute la famille, quoi.
Y a eu Jacques, Philippe, Arthur, Géraldine, Audrey, Fifi, et Pascaline.
Puis voilà quoi, je crois que c'est tout... Ah non, y a eu Jérémy aussi.
C'est bien, c'est bien...
Merci pour tout, à bientôt.
SALUT CINDY !